cameron diaz is one of hollywood's most
beloved and highest grossing movie
actresses of all time who does not
remember that scene from something about
mary she has spent most of the past
decade off camera but just a few weeks
ago diaz announced her return to the
screen yay in a new netflix film with
jamie foxx cbs saturday morning co-host
that's dana jacobson spoke with diaz
about why she took a break from acting
and how she's been spending her time and
it involves some wine good wine dana
good morning
during the pandemic cameron diaz did
launch a wine label aveline it was with
her friend businesswoman catherine power
it's a new arena but it brought diaz who
quit acting back in 2014 back into the
spotlight
[Music]
when the blockbuster comedy the mask hit
theaters in 1994
cameron diaz just 21 at the time
became one of hollywood's most sought
after actresses i know it's crazy
leading roles i work alone in every
genre
soon followed
but in 2014 after 20 years this is
happiness and 40 memorable roles
surprise diaz made the decision to hit
pause on acting
at a time when she was the highest paid
actress over 40. at the top of your game
when you leave your career
why did you leave it behind when you're
doing something that you know and you've
done well and you've you know how it
works and it's consumed your whole life
for so long it's kind of a nice thing to
kind of go you know what let me just
step back for a second take a look
at what you know what the whole picture
looks like for me and what are the
things that i could do better and be
more engaged with that would make me
feel more whole
and i did that do you miss acting i mean
i miss aspects of acting or making
movies
yeah making movies is a particular skill
set that is fun to exercise and be a
part of but yeah life is it's a
different lifestyle and you kind of have
to be ready to do that now after an
eight-year hiatus she's ready to return
to the big screen in a film aptly titled
back in action starring alongside jamie
foxx everybody only has 100 and you
always have to figure out how you're
going to divide up that 100 percent
to spread it to all the parts of your
life that matter right much of what
matters today is family a year after
stepping out of the spotlight she
married benji madden lead guitarist for
the rock band good charlotte they're now
parents to a two and a half year old
daughter who they've chosen to keep out
of the public eye has motherhood changed
you yeah
definitely what do you enjoy most about
it
gosh
i think just
the um being able to
you know
have influence and on a child that's
developing yeah you know all mothers
have that moment where you're watching
your child and they're doing something
first time and you're like i remember
doing that it's really cool cameron
those are good knife skills one of
diaz's other loves cooking food is my
love language you know i love that it's
feeding
my husband married me because of my
cooking uncertain
a passion that goes back to her
childhood memories of cooking every
night with her mom
my mom is still my favorite cook my
mom's food is the food that i want to
eat because it's like the food i that i
associate with my heart you know and
it's only natural that her love of food
goes hand in hand with her love of wine
i'm curious i want information i want
knowledge about you know first how my
body works then how my body ages and
then how does it wine work that
curiosity led her to aveline an organic
and vegan wine label she launched in
2020 with her friend and entrepreneur
catherine power we realized that it
really starts with the grape from the
beginning we were told that we couldn't
do it
you know there were a lot of obstacles
in trying to bring you know this clean
delicious wine these organically grown
grapes and
this kind of wine with these kind of
standards to market their company
started out just as girl talk over a
glass of wine wondering what it was they
were consuming and they quickly learned
it was often more than just fermented
grapes there are over 70 additives that
can be added to wine during the wine
making process without any disclosure so
you know you're just not aware of what
is going into your glass when you know
if you eat something you're able to look
at the nutritional information and the
ingredient list you know also the
majority of vineyards here in the united
states are not organic and often farm
with harmful you know chemical
pesticides they made a commitment to
source their grapes from organic farmers
from around the world they also took a
closer look at the wine filtering
process the thing that shocked me in
reading about your wine
wine has to be vegan right i mean people
look at it it's wine wine is vegan
apparently not all wine is vegan yeah i
mean i remember the moment we learned
that we both were like what we looked at
each other
we're like where do you how
to us
oftentimes wine is fine or filtered
using animal by-products so
we you know learned that and we thought
god what about the people that are you
know vegan who are consuming wine and
they don't even know that because it's
not typically put on a bottle
transparency is the cause they're
championing and their main goal is
simply to offer wine drinkers another
option
having avaline in the market is just
one step closer to you know providing
an industry with a you know a road map
you know something they may have not
considered before the decision to launch
aveline seems to have been an easy one
for diaz who has long been committed to
health and wellness writing two books on
the subject one focused on aging your
second book to me
seemed
unpredictable for somebody in hollywood
it talked about aging yeah and doing it
gracefully not saying let me not age
it was about letting yourself age yeah
well i mean looking aging is something
you can't stop but you can just do it as
good as you possibly can but
what helps you do it more gracefully the
total experience of aging not just sort
of the one aspect that we're so focused
on
um the look of it which by the way no
judgment if people want like i don't
have any like if it makes you feel
better great but also don't ignore all
the other aspects of what is happening
as you as you go along that journey
so diaz turns 50 this year and you hear
her talk about priorities so many of us
have gone through this how do i do
everything and she was so committed to
that acting career that it was i need to
step back so i can figure out how to do
some of these other things too so yeah i
get it i imagine she likes being a mom
i'm always cheering for her i think i
think she's not only a great actress i
think she's a great human being she's so
fun she's got a great personality yeah
the wine good the wine was good and it's
funny because we came upon this story
natasha sing the producer and i were
having glasses of wine saying we should
do a story on hawaii let's look up and
natasha found that cameron had this wine
and their story was so similar that it
was one of those conversations with
girlfriends
how can we do this
right they had girls talk
they had girl talking that's why the
wine i i was shocked to know that she'd
been retired from acting because she
hadn't done a film in 10 years because
it feels like i see her often on my
television screen if something about
mary is on
i like the holiday all of those yeah and
i just watch it because she's ubiquitous
yeah so it's great and like acting she
is such a part of this business she's
not just putting her name to it she's a
part of it and jamie foxx together
that'll be fun that'll be great dana
thank you for your follow-up question
isn't all wine i know right
i have no idea i would have thought yes